and today's webinar is a
information system a session about
a project
at Austin becomes School of Business
but let's move on we'll be joined today
by Timothy Jerome
that's what Austin becomes School of
Business
boot camp
but let's move on we'll be joined today
by Timothy Jerome
this is awesome to come School of
Business
apologize for that a little Network
problem on this end
as I mentioned we'll be joined by
Timothy Jerome who is one of our senior
PMP trainers uh he'll be substituting
for Brian Campbell today
and uh he'll be joining us in a few
minutes
what we're going to talk about today is
a project management careers We'll be
asking you a few poll questions along
the way about yourselves
um
we'll talk about what this program
offers and how it gets you job ready
and we'll cover enrollment steps and
we'll take your questions
my name is Stuart Creek I'm with simply
learn I am
part of the organization that is the
delivery partner for UT Austin for this
program
and I'll be your
post today let's talk a little bit about
careers in project management
Pardon Me project management is a
universal skill it's
something that applies to every aspect
of business and organizations
um
and
product management project management
has changed a great deal over the
especially in recent years
um
modern project management recruits
Frameworks and tools and digital skills
that allow you to manage complex and
transformational projects large projects
very involved projects
much different from the
uh past environment of simple waterfall
project management or
Gantt charts of that type of thing
project management
is a
evolving field and there are new
techniques that are available and it has
applications in every industry and every
company everything
that we do that involves some type of
planning for actions in the future
uh can be looked at through a project
management lens
it's important because project
management
involves setting expectations
appropriately
so that people can understand what
they're going to get when they're going
to get it how much it will cost
um
and
all of that has to be balanced so that
it meets the objectives of your
organization or your business
so
as we say that's different financially
you need to be able to develop a project
plan and at your deliverables according
to the plan you need to be able to
recruit the appropriate resources
including individuals
um you need to be able to lead and
manage your team
but requires leadership skills
you need to apply the correct
methodology for the project ending on
what type of project it is what the
scope is you need to establish a project
schedule
um so that you can plan out how you're
going to deliver and according to what
timetable
uh you need to be able to appropriately
assign tasks to team members
so that the work is divided
appropriately and people use their
skills to the best of their ability
and you need to be able to communicate
progress to your upper management you
need to be able to communicate any
issues that may come up request
resources
uh all of that is extremely important in
process of project management so it's
not a closed system
it's something that involves working
with all the parts of your organization
and
you need a suite of skills
and Tim has just joined us Timothy uh
good to see you
you're on mute
there you go good day Stuart how are you
I'm great uh so Timothy I was just
talking about um
the universidality of project management
you might be able to comment on on a few
slides here so
uh yeah
yeah I can I can speak quickly to this
um and and by the way uh did you
introduce me yet Stuart
um briefly so you can give yourself uh a
more thorough introduction
a lot over 18 years project management
and preparing for the PMP exam I've
taught over 10 000 students I'm a
research advisor and analyst I interact
with leaders in the industry I take on
two or three mentors who uh report into
CEOs a billion dollar a year
corporations
um I I play with that
um this this is this is my joy I live to
help project managers with their Career
Development and part of that is uh help
them gain their PMP credential how's
that that's perfect and
um so yeah if you would like to talk
about how project management is
different today from
what it was
you began
boy oh boy okay so so let's let's let's
do a little history of project
management and uh I'll make this quick
for everybody so we've always done
projects right project is just a group
of work that has a start and an amp and
it creates something that uh
has a purpose and mostly uh corporations
non-profit organizations create a uh um
create a project that fulfills a
business need and they're willing to set
aside time money and resources and
somebody to manage this because it's a
critical change that's why project
management exists it started as a formal
career path back right after World War
II in the United States with
um the Navy and the Coast Guard and they
created a set of tools and they said
here's some scope tools schedule tools
and budget tools we need to look at and
then they started looking at this in in
the early to mid 1960s they said hey
it's much more than scope schedule and
budget it has to be stuff like resources
human and physical resources has to be
something like uh communication because
I'm working with teams and stakeholders
has to take in to account contracts so
it's pulling all these things together
now
something really strange happened in
2015.
um the project management Institute was
catching wind of this earlier and they
were working with research analysts and
they said you know what we're going to
have to learn not just how to do these
technical things they called them
process focused activities right they
said
we need to learn management and
Leadership because a lot of your work is
not telling people to do stuff and
making them wrong a lot of their work is
influence and motivating them so the
exam back in 1918 uh 2018 and 2019
started being focused half of it
on that stuff right on leadership and
then they said you know you got to learn
a little bit about business because
projects impact business and how do
project and business work together and
then finally they said here and and this
made that change in 2020 I think
agile's important and project managers
are not going away because why
what's the role of a scrum master in
budget
what's the role of a an agile expert
in managing contracts and so we had to
Define this whole framework that
incorporates business and process and
Leadership together and and so it's a
it's not just a technical framework
oh yeah it's it's it's a frightening
thing and and yeah this is how change
happens and it became such a great set
of tools that from 1984 when the when
the exam first came became public
um it was automatically recognized not
just as a nice to have but as a need to
have for business and business says this
is our new Brass Ring to help us become
successful
so there's a whole Suite of different
functions that from the traditional view
of project management but as you as you
pointed out Tim that there's
their interaction and their interplay is
very different today than um looking at
each of these in isolation
I I was just talking with one of my
friends he runs 100 million and 300
million dollar projects for states in
the United States and he said when he
started it was all rules and tools and
arts and charts right follow the thing
and formally change but
we can't do that now the world's crazier
um we all know what's been happening
here
it's from 2018 to 2020 to 2023. you know
it we have what what do we have we have
Luca we have volatility uncertainty
complexity and ambiguity and change is a
constant so our understanding of
projects and project management has to
incorporate the ability to manage within
that change and still be successful yeah
and as you're pointing out that the
the importance of project management and
the ability to do it in a modern fashion
is incredibly
vital uh
look at examples for uh
the state of Oregon a few years ago
wanted to in Implement new systems at a
Statewide level and contracted with
Oracle Corporation
and
the entire process fell apart and
to basically that was a major failure of
project management and
so with those kinds of spectacular
failures as cautionary examples
it just highlights how important it is
to to
um understand the different aspects of
project management and to be able to
apply them intelligently
so that you can um
yeah take on like you said the the vuca
environment of uncertainty and
ambiguity and be able to adapt as
the situation around you changes keep
your project going towards the goal that
you're you're seeking
so these are some of the skills that uh
you teach
ings
we simply learned and uh UT Austin so
um
I don't know if you want to comment on
on these but these are all aspects as
you mentioned of
modern project management as opposed to
the and she said
arts and charts yeah so so yeah you're
right exactly and and it's not that we
need to be certified as project managers
in all these areas right what we need to
know is how do I identify the experts
who can help us with these pieces and
how to integrate or bring these in as
part of those and and what the value of
each one of these areas of knowledge are
our our job is not to play a trombone or
play a trumpet or play a fruit flute
when it's needed it's how do we weave
all these things together and what we're
talking about with these bullets on this
screen are different instruments that
we've learned over the last 20 to 40
years that are really valuable for the
problems that are hitting us right now
in our society
so I have a poll question for the
audience and this first poll question is
um you're all here because you're
interested in project management as a
field what has stopped you from uh
taking
course of this type or program of this
type
is it because you can't find that kind
of pre-comprehensive curriculum that
covers
the tools skills and and Concepts that
Kim was talking about is it because you
don't feel that a program would give you
practical experience that you can
demonstrate is it because you find it
difficult to learn from
you know pre-recorded self-paced videos
or is it because your work schedule
is
so a tight that you don't feel you have
enough time to fit in learning
I'll leave this open for another 15 or
20 seconds as the answers continue to
come in
all right the numbers have stopped
changing so I'm going to go ahead and
close the poll
share the results with you
um
sixty percent of the audience
worried that they wouldn't get practical
exposure to demonstrate the skills
they've learned
and then the other uh
next most common answer is finding time
in your work schedule
so let's talk about
uh how this this program from UT Austin
works
the project management boot camp which
is offered by the McCombs School of
Business business at University of Texas
at Austin
um it's a six-month program
we say that it takes about 10 or 15
hours of commitment of time each week
um by the way the QR code will take you
to the program page if you're interested
um so it's a comprehensive curriculum
and we'll get into that in a moment but
it's aligned with the needs of Industry
so that at the end of this process
you have a set of skills
knowledge that is
suitable for the needs of Industry
integrated case studies and Hands-On
projects that all happen on the same
platform it's all delivered digitally
online
online live virtual classes that you
take a weekly that
let you interact with instructors like
Timothy and
um
be able to to get your questions
answered directly follow on with them as
they take you through exercises it'll
let you interact with your peers in the
class
um on the same
digital platform you have access to your
projects case studies all in the
sandboxed environment so that you a
virtual machine that you can do work on
you don't need to have
a separate set of tools necessarily on
your own desktop
you can access it from anywhere a lot of
the material
Preparatory materials between classes
for example are things that you can
watch on your mobile device whenever you
want so with a 24x7 access to the
platform you can schedule your work
other than the
scheduled classes you can work on your
other
coursework anytime during the week
whenever you feel like it you can have
support if you're working on a project
at three in the morning and
you need help you can contact a 24x7
help desk uh you can ask professors and
mail them and get an answer in the
morning and that type of thing so
this is a
great program to fit into any schedule
and it covers the gamut of
project management skills
the end of the process you received your
certificate from University of Texas
McCombs School of Business
and that certifies that you've completed
the courses in the program and
demonstrated your skills including
through the Capstone project at the end
of the program
so you've done the Hands-On case studies
and Projects please become part of your
portfolio along with your Capstone
project
something that you can then show off to
Uh current employer or potential future
employers master classes with
instructors from UT Austin
you get a Alumni Association membership
um and we'll talk about other support
services that we provide so
um I'm going to ask Tim in a few minutes
to talk about the Capstone project
because that's
really important process
but I'm going to mention the University
of Texas at Austin founded 140 years ago
it currently ranks within the top 40
universities in the world
um the business school is celebrating uh
just celebrated its 100th anniversary
and this program gives you the
certificate master classes Alumni
Association and 146
pdus for professional development
um with 35 contact hours so this is a
great part of the process of getting
certified
and so having UTA on your CV something
that people will recognize worldwide
great institution we're very proud to be
the delivery partner with them
so for this program you don't need
extensive prerequisites but you do need
work experience so I
educational requirement is just a high
school diploma or equivalent must be 18
years of age of course and then
you need to have a minimum of five years
of work experience in any given field it
does not have to be in project
management
um you do not have to have a background
in programming or technology
um because you'll gain whatever skills
you need in that aspect through the
program itself
um can you Tim uh talk a little bit
about why work experience is such an
important prerequisite
and you're not unmute yourself there
thanks for that Stuart
um so when we talk about learning and
education inside of project management
we just don't talk about skills we talk
about
knowledge and attributes attributes is
the behavior and character that actually
you need in approaching some
situations within projects and project
management and so
um these this this five years of work
experience is exposure for not just you
know a checklist that you can follow but
learning to work in and around a
a uh the look and feel of what projects
are people people learn so much and it's
it's not just you know recognition
learning it's comprehension learning so
when you come to the a um a a learning
structure such as this you bring all of
this work history so your questions are
not you know how do I build a
spreadsheet your questions is why does
it have to be that we do these things in
this order so all of a sudden it it
gives you you know it gives you what we
call context the background surrounding
information to get to that comprehension
quickly yeah and understanding the
context of project management within an
organization it's something that this
experience gives you so that's
um let me ask another question then from
the audience
um just to give an idea of who's out in
today's audience
how much experience do you have
this uh just a few seconds while we're
waiting
the numbers have stopped changing so I'm
gonna go ahead and close the poll
and two-thirds of our audience are
people with more than five years of
experience so
great those are the the folks that
has qualified for the program so
it's good to see that there's that much
experience out there for people who are
in the
in school still or your years of
experience
um
this is something you want to keep in
mind for for the future maybe look at
other uh potential programs that we have
but this
the folks who are in the more than five
years category this is a great
great option so
moving on how the program prepares you
and Tim if you are able to
talk about
um
the curriculum how we build up the
uh
set of courses so that they follow in a
logical sequence that
enables success in each success of
course
yeah I'll be happy to
um I'll just take about half a minute
for each one of these so with
certification training
um It prepares you to pass
the uh PMP certification exam which is a
bit of a complex exam one of the things
that you have to remember is it's not
the the exam actually is not
memorization it's you know how to do
these tasks of a project manager so the
exam teaches you how to do things and
what's the right approach and what type
of attitude do you need to approach it
with so with with that uh with that
training you don't just get a you know
what are the tools and how do I use the
tools but but again you know what
knowledge do I need as a project manager
and what uh character
um with with agile and scrum master all
of a sudden you start looking at the
vuca work right volatility uncertainty
complexity and ambiguity like you know
like your corporation has just been
called into lockdown and how do I manage
within that right and agile
is that adaptive attitude and and we go
through the attitude you need to do the
work and scrum
is a framework which brings the tools
and so together with agile attitude and
scrum tools you actually learn that
extension that makes your project
management that much more effective
because those tools you know they're
necessary in adaptive projects but
they're actually
a beneficial in traditional project
management now Microsoft Project's
interesting it's it's a great tool and
and once you have the fundamentals of
project management through project
management professional certification
and agile scrum you can start using this
base to explore how do I
how do I build a plan
how do I collect the data how do I
analyze the data and generate the ports
I need to manage the work and then on
top of that
you start saying okay I understand about
projects
but how do projects fit within the
organization like I said we were talking
about
business people and process at the
beginning of this discussion the pmo is
that is that centralized organization
that interacts with the business and so
as a project manager one of your
lifelines and your knowledge bases your
pmo so how do I build one how do I work
with one what's necessary for a pmo to
be successful in an organization that
answers that class and this is where we
say
do you want to be a pmo director
do you want to be a program manager
do you want to be an expert in building
the corporations knowledge base in doing
projects and project management well so
this program doesn't just make you a
good project manager and makes you an
effective uh knowledge worker within the
corporation
I can talk to you that's great um can
you mention a little bit about the
electives because the electives are
included in the course at no additional
cost they're all based on whether the
individual learner wants to take those
classes
the desire and the time to do that so
can you cover some of those
sure sure so the PMP professional uh
certification
is there and it's part of it right and
and the training itself is is one of the
basic fundamentals now digital
transformation is interesting uh this
speaks to the understanding that one of
our major focuses for the next 50 years
is going to be Automation and the
introduction of new technology like AI
into our businesses and business
decision making and and so this actually
prepares you to start thinking about how
your clients how your stakeholders and
how your company can best do this
movement into the information
um uh stage of our civilization
um
Six Sigma
is really fascinating because we learned
in the middle of the 20th century you
can't just do work you have to do it
well you have to do it correctly now we
talk about that in project management in
quality but with this lean Six Sigma
Green Belt it gives you an opportunity
to get an initial certification in
understanding how to build quality into
your work and so bringing that back into
your project you have an opportunity to
number one you know have
as quality expert is part of your team
but also understand how to do project
management and apply quality to your
project management work and then finally
risk is one of the it's it's one of the
fundamental tools and an extension of
risk is not just uh managing potential
threats but also managing potential
opportunities and so this this whole
understanding of preparing you for the
risk management professional
certification is exposing you to the
full spectrum
of how do I manage risk not just to
protect my project but make it even more
successful
excellent
um I also mentioned the project
management master classes from UT Austin
instructors
so those are ways to get insight into
industry practice from the professors
and also into into more of the
um theoretical background in some of
those aspects so
um some of the tools that get exposed to
in the in the we mentioned Microsoft
Project also Microsoft Excel jira
um so these are some of the tools that
you
um learn to use in the program
so that you can
confidently state that you're capable
and qualified in those so those tools
Capstone project and we mentioned that
before
um is a opportunity to choose a real
world industry-based project problem
solve
and develop Your solution in your way
under the mentorship of an instructor
like Timothy or someone else who would
um
meet with you weekly to keep you on
track and make sure that you're not
getting
stuck down any rabbit holes or dead ends
but um to keep you
in the process of building that
project management solution for the
problem and
real world data sets
Virtual Lab so that you can do this all
on the
digital platform
and submit your project at the end for
evaluation that becomes essentially your
final exam for the program and uh
gets evaluated to qualify you for the
final program certificate
um Tim if you
involved been involved in Capstone
project mentorship
um I have absolutely
um I I can give it a little context to
that yeah so so
let's actually talk about what the
learning experience is you're online
you're going through materials you're
validating that you're learning you're
talking to an expert who can actually
say here let me clarify your doubts let
me give you a little more context all of
a sudden in a Capstone project you're
put in a real world
experience now
wouldn't it be nice if you had a new job
like a project manager of a new project
and you had somebody to bounce ideas off
of this is called mentoring
um somebody with 20 years of experience
like me and and my experience has to do
with
um you know building integrated
Technical Systems building data centers
helping corporations make these
transformation decisions that were
either make or break for for Fortune 50s
and Fortune 100s wouldn't you like to
have somebody to bounce ideas off of
when you had doubts with this project
it's it's it's having that human touch
to say you know
um let's let's talk about this and let's
do a little uh role play and let's let's
practice some things before we actually
make some decisions in the project this
is this is the value you're you're
actually working with an approach
project environment with ongoing active
human support
thank you so
that gives you a feel for how this works
and the value for it
Dr Christopher Burke is the program
advisor from UT Austin
um
develop the curriculum
oversees the delivery
so that he assigns the UT Austin
instructors who give the master classes
and that type of thing so he's
responsible for the content and quality
of the program
and make sure that we simply learn
delivering it according to UT Austin's
uh own standards so that they can
confidently issue certificates to our
program graduates
um
Tim I'm going to ask if you have access
to you are you able to uh
share your screen and demonstrate this
or is that available to you I don't have
access to this okay I just wanted to ask
I will uh
let you describe how this works in terms
of
you know what the
Learning Management platform looks like
so can you describe how how students um
manage the curriculum and interact
sure
um I can give a general overview
um it it's it it depends on the various
um parts of the curriculum but basically
there's a centralized repository that
allows you to schedule and participate
in your work in your work like set up my
classes know when my classes are and
also it it has links and information to
all that you need there right like how
do I stay in touch with other students
how do I stay in touch with the
educator and and then on top of that
um you know you have access to other
other tools for your research where
where do I need to go for you know
um
for more information
um what what's coming up and and what do
I have to be working on so it has the
syllabus and it has the schedule but on
top of that it also has an interactive
session that that helps you with
communication there's there's a forum
base which helps you with what we call
both synchronous and asynchronous
communication the synchronous
communication allows you to interact
with like what we're doing right now
questions and answers and validation
works really well and we also have
asynchronous communication you have you
have a work and a home life and and
everybody else that's participating in
this has a work in a home life wouldn't
it be great if you could have an
extended conversation much like texting
or WhatsApp and that Forum environment
allows you to continually interact when
I was teaching project management back
in 2004 even up to 2010
um once the classes were over the
professors left
and what I've been finding was simply
learned specially is these days you have
interaction with the students and the
experts way past
um way past the end of the class it's
it's almost like an extension of a
mentoring environment and it's not just
the people who you're interacting with
in the class it's interacting with other
students it's it's
um it's wonderful now why is this
important it's called engagement if you
want to really get through these
programs well it's staying involved and
you know with with this program please I
think you'll be really happy with how it
supports keeping you involved and
motivated and moving forward but at the
same time evaluate these type of
programs by how they keep you there
answering your questions being effective
in clarifying doubt and helping you with
these obstacles
and I think you'll be very satisfied
um with with your answers as you
evaluate this program
um as we also mentioned it is and as you
mentioned the support tools include the
Forum where you can interact with
instructors as well as your peers in the
program
um we have a 24x7 support desk available
that answers both questions about the
platform itself how it works but also
about the subject matter you can tap
into the subject matter experts if
you've reached a doubt or a blocker
during the middle of a
middle of the night when you're working
on a project
um
and it also
gives you the ability to track through
your program step by step so that as you
complete each module it unlocks that
module gives you a certificate for that
module and then allows you to it unlocks
the next module I should say allows you
to start that second
but next
part of the program in sequence that's
to keep you on track gives you reminders
and prompts to make sure that you're
staying on track keeps track of your
attendance all of that new to make sure
that
you're being
kept accountable for your progress in
the program that you have the maximum
chance of success
you can talk about learner outcomes
one of the learner outcomes that we
help to facilitate is finding a job so
with our career assist we do not
guarantee that you will find a job but
we provide you with tools
that make your job search
that much more effective so
provide access to ongoing
continuing educational webinars and
career events
we provide of course the portfolio of
projects that you develop during the
program itself
that become part of your
permanent portfolio that you demonstrate
to potential employers and then we
provide job assist Services through our
partner Talent Inc these include access
to the resume rabbit job portal with
exclusive job listings which is a
valuable part of the program I think the
more valuable Parts actually fall in the
resume review and rewrite
one-on-one interview service um
today
resumes have to go through an i AI bot
as part of the automated tracking
systems that companies use
and the AI bot will filter out
resumes that by whether they match the
job description
understanding how to format your resume
so that the
information is accessible and
understandable to the AI process
uh is important but your resume then
also has to be formatted so it's
attractive when it lands on the the desk
or the
uh screen of a human evaluator so
the ability to to
fulfill both of those requirements as
kind of an art form and that's one of
the great things
resume rewrite service helps you with
um
same thing applies to interviewing you
have
a couple different types of interviews
that you'll be called on to do
if you're called in if your resume makes
it through that filter and called for an
interview you're going to have to do
phone interviews Zoom interviews
possibly in person live interviews some
of them are going to be
based on your skill set and evaluating a
technical standpoint some of them will
be evaluating you as a team member as a
fit to company culture
uh
evaluating your work style so
having the access to one-on-one
preparation sessions for both of those
kinds of interview types is a really
valuable aspect that helps you get
prepared for your job search again these
Services extend for six months after you
receive your certificate and
um so they're based on your level of
demand and how much you want to use them
how effectively you want to use them for
your job search
so
um again we don't force them on you or
guarantee a job
offer from them but we do give you all
the support that you can ask for in
terms of preparing for a job search and
conducting it so
uh we talked about the webinars you can
look at different skills they'll be
sessions on project management
techniques or what the state of the
industry is many courses a one-hour
lesson on
a particular aspect
of a particular
skill how to develop your career with
things like how do
you use a job board to find a job
how to uh apply different principles to
your career development and all of these
are for free
offered by simply learn
so you have access to those and then as
we talked about the different
uh projects that you showcased within
your portfolio and these are examples of
different
Capstone project options
if I choose a problem from fintech or
from computer gaming or from
Communications or from Information
Technology and
as you can see these are
case study type problems of real world
situations and then you design your
solution
under the mentorship of your instructor
so
um based on what
Timothy and I have told you today what
you've seen so far is this something
that you would be interested in
enrolling it
we'll leave this question open short for
a short period of time considering it's
a yes or no
please get your answers in
we'll leave this open for another five
seconds
four
three
two
one
almost ninety percent of the people who
responded said they are interested in
the program so let me share with you
uh that process
but first we'll talk about the
enrollment steps it's pretty
straightforward and I will put into the
chat
um
the email address asked us at
simplylearn.net as well as the link to
the program page so you can look at the
other materials about it
and into the chat
right now
okay once you've emailed us and talked
to our learning Consultants they will uh
take your proof of employment history
the other information that you need to
submit and they will review your
application and if you're qualified if
evaluation shows that you have a really
great chance of successfully completing
the program we'll send you an admission
offer
the next cohort of these classes starts
February 17th with an orientation the
classes themselves oops start March 18th
the program fee is six thousand dollars
and it can be financed for as low as 528
dollars a month zero percent financing
we recommend that you contact your
employer HR department a Learning and
Development Department find out if they
offer tuition reimbursement program
that might cover all a part of the cost
of the program
and that'll be your your own employer's
policies but
um we always recommend that people check
on that
so to get the process started do reach
out to us at ask us at simplylearn.net
it's one
question before we get to the Q a
which is
if you are interested how soon would you
like to start are you looking at the
cohort where classes start in March or
something
soon thereafter or further down the road
we always say that this is if this is
something that is going to positively
change your life and career it's always
worth doing sooner than later
this open for about another 10 seconds
we'll close this poll three two
one
and I was looking at the patterns this
is a flat distribution
so about 50 percent of
the audience are interested in this
coming cohort or the one right after
um so you want to contact us ask us at
simplylearn.net and get that process
started if you're looking more than six
months out or more than three months out
please do contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net and we will answer any
questions you have and keep you in the
loop for future cohorts
with that
let me
give some time for Timothy and me to
answer questions so I'm going to oops
stop sharing
you don't need to stare at the slide I
don't think
and I will go through
q a here
so if you have questions that you put
into the chat please
retype them into the Q a because it's
much easier for me to find them
um I don't own asks about prospects for
traditional project management in light
of adoption of agile
um
are
is there a distinction between quote
unquote traditional project managers and
project managers qualified in agile
scrum another
techniques
go ahead Tim you'd answer that yes
um you know what's funny uh it if if you
look at the data they like to
differentiate it based on the approach
to the work right traditional schedule
project management says I know the work
well and we're going to focus on a plan
where adaptive methods are most like we
don't know what what the work is so we
have to focus on the relationships well
you talk to somebody who's a traditional
project manager for 15 years you know
they're getting paid 75 to 125 dollars
an hour and they say you know what you
look at adaptive methods and it's common
sense and and about about five to ten
years in you start learning about the
benefits of these adaptive methods so
you just naturally come to you know
building them into your traditional
project management now that being said
there are certain industries that say we
are going to do project management at
racial method right like Pharmaceuticals
you have to have that well controlled
well discipline structure Fuel and oil
energy projects have to be very well
controlled so they like traditional and
construction is another one of these
areas but like research and like
education and even government to a great
extent
um they it's it's really beneficial for
you to understand the two methods and
why and how to apply them and then you
need a Capstone and getting into the
work you can actually say wow I don't
have two tool kits anymore I'm effective
no matter what project I'm dropped into
um are they also asked a question um
he was certified
lost a certification when he moved to
North America because of the financial
concern about renewal
and would like to know what are the
advantages of a program like this that
go over and above
the
PMP
they have qualification
so so the PMP qualification is
PMI
has tested and evaluated you and they're
saying to the public this person is now
an expert
this person has this level of Knowledge
and Skills and they've demonstrated they
can perform project management within
that now I got my PMP back in 2003 and
every time I recertified I had to
either get more training or do more
research myself or do other things that
kept me current and so the current exam
says you know it's going to be 50 50
adaptive and traditional project
management and it's going to be 40
percent on leadership alone with 50
percent looking at what we have been
tested on in in the past years so it the
mix is a little different so from an is
this necessary to a great extent it's
going to make what's necessary to the
changes in the exam a lot easier now
when we talk about beneficials it's
incredibly beneficial because you don't
just get the ability to pass the exam
you get the ability to you know work and
explore and develop in a relationship
that supports comprehension not just you
know not just the Book of Knowledge
thank you
um
we have an anonymous question we're
somewhat related um
so that they've
taken training for the PMP exam they
would like to know whether
um it makes sense to take the boot camp
program and take the actual exam
afterward or whether they could take the
exam
prior to completing the boot camp
there are a lot of factors involved
first of all first of all when when
you've you know quote unquote gone
through a boot camp or you've quote
unquote earned those 35 contact hours
you can use those 35 contact hours from
years ago like if you were with me back
in 2012 and you got a year year contact
hours back then
it works but but the thing is it's not
current and it's it's you know it it
doesn't reflect what what has changed in
project management uh that's that's the
big detail now do I have to get my PMP
you know that's that's personal
preference what the PMP does is it
exposes you to all the aspects of what
project management is and means and
gives you the opportunity to practice it
and explore it and integrate it into
your personal toolkit thank you Joel is
currently working in the oil and gas
industry in India with and is planning
to move to North America uh in June and
is curious to know if uh this type of
project management training is useful in
that industry
yes and in fact
um I I worked in three sectors within
energy and one of them was Fuel and oil
and a lot of mine was
um was uh working with construction as
well as the management of refinement and
and think about this if a project is
change think about how an energy
corporation over the last 20 minute uh
20 years has had to adopt to change all
the governance right authorizations and
signatures that have changed and and
have to be applied and then compliance
are we following proper process and
procedure and so number one project
management itself has had to adapt to
how the energy industry is is working
and number two projects are a really
nice way for an energy Fuel and oil
company to actually say we're doing this
correctly see we have a project manager
who has a list of signatures and has a
list of quality assurance and have a
list of Occupational Safety help
occupational safety and health
compliance it's all packaged within what
we call a project
um we have an anonymous question to
students that finish the Capstone still
have to take the PMP exam and those two
things are kind of separate in the sense
of the Capstone is giving you a
the demonstrated skills along the lines
of this program but if you want the
official
PMP certification from the project
management Institute you need to take
their exam separately however the boot
camp includes preparation for the exam
so
um
the things kind of go hand in hand but
they they aren't uh identical to each
other
um what are some of the quicker options
Randy asked what are some of the quicker
options that result in PMP certification
through simply learn
and you know outside of this boot camp
program we do have
separate focused
certification programs that Focus simply
on the
what you need to know in order to pass
the the PMP to become qualified at that
level so that it's not just
learning how to answer the questions and
just learning the skills but they're
it's focused centrally on
you've done a number of those courses
haven't you yeah Stuart can I give you
some data yeah over over the last two
decades and working with 10 000 people
okay I've known three people who picked
up a book studied and passed the exam
period
um if you're working in a peer-based
group industry studies research from
places like Forester and Gartner and
other places that look at education and
edtech
um 50 to 75 percent of the people in a
peer boost based group where you have a
bunch of students teaching each other uh
past the exam the first time when when
you start getting a formal
infrastructure like we have with an
expert LED and facilitated environment
you get to a 95 to a 98 chance of
passing and that's one of the reasons
why this is powerful and that now put on
top of that what we're talking about is
getting the knowledge and attributes and
getting the experience on top of this it
makes for a very interesting package
um and a last question from
asna who says what do you say about
when companies are looking for
experience
how does this program
because PMP doesn't
particularly ask for certified that you
have experience but this boot camp
program
differs from that actually actually this
this is what's interesting to apply for
the PMP exam
you need to have two to three actually
what is it 36 months or 60 months of
demonstrated
leading and managing projects so the PMP
demonstrates this person has been quote
unquote managing and doing projects and
also
shows their expertise in that so even
the PMP has both those facets of it it's
it's it's it's really a wild credential
yeah thank you for that correction I
appreciate that um but in the boot camp
program itself
takes you into
experiential learning with different
projects up to and including the
Capstone so that that adds to your your
basis
um okay and
that is all the time we have for the
questions so I'm going to
apologize if we didn't get to your
question
I think we got to most of them
um but I will ask one last question of
you in the audience
and
that is
simply if you are interested in
joining the program
my computer is not going to crash out on
me
it may do
if I can launch this poll
give me a moment please be patient